>> Ainsley: IT IS DISTURBING
NEW DATA AND IT SHOWS WHAT IT
MIGRANTS ON THE TERROR WATCH
LIST I'VE BEEN ARRESTED TRYING
TO ENTER OUR COUNTRY ILLEGALLY
SINCE JOE BIDEN TOOK OFFICE.
THOSE NUMBERS RELEASED AFTER A
REQUEST FROM CONGRESSMAN
CHIP ROY TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY.
CONGRESSMAN CHIP ROY JOINS US
NOW.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU,
CONGRESSMAN.
>> Ainsley: YOU ARE SLAMMING
JOE BIDEN FOR BLAMING THEM FOR
THE 42 PEOPLE WITH TERRORIST
SIZES SNEAKING INTO OUR COUNTRY.
MANY MORE DID SNEAK IN THAT WE
DIDN'T CATCH?
WHAT LED TO THAT?
WHAT LED TO THE INVESTIGATION
TRYING TO FIND OUT THE TRUE
NUMBERS?
>> YOU ARE ASKING THE QUESTION
THAT EVERY AMERICAN IS ASKING
RIGHT NOW AND JEN PSAKI IS
DISMISSING.
BILL MELUGIN IS OUT THERE DOING
SUCH GREAT REPORTING.
HE HAD SEEN SOMETHING LIKE 23 OR
GOT INFORMATION THAT THERE WERE
23.
WE GOT THE INFORMATION THE SAME
DAY OR WEEK.
WE SENT A LETTER LAST AUGUST.
IT TOOK EIGHT MONTHS.
MY OFFICE FINALLY GOT A RESPONSE
BACK A MONTH LATER FOR THE
DETAILED QUESTIONS WE HAD ASKED.
ONE OF WHICH THEY ANSWERED
INDICATING THAT THERE WERE 42
INDIVIDUALS ARRESTED WITH KNOWN
TIES TO, YOU KNOW, TERRORISTS.
THEY WERE ON THE TERROR WATCH
LIST.
THAT'S A REAL PROBLEM.
THE THING IS, JEN PSAKI
DISMISSES THAT AND SAYS THAT'S
.000 X OF THE ENCOUNTER.
JEN PSAKI CAN'T TELL US HOW MANY
PEOPLE HAVE COME INTO OUR
COUNTRY WHO ARE KNOWN GOT AWAYS.
WE KNOW FROM THE INTELLIGENCE WE
ARE LOOKING AT IN THE
INFORMATION WE GET FROM BORDER
PATROL AGENTS THAT THERE HAS
BEEN SOME 5,000, 600,000, MAYBE
700,000 KNOWN GOT AWAYS.
THEY ARE THE WORST ACTORS WHO
COME INTO THE UNITED STATES.
IN ADDITION TO THE 42
INDIVIDUALS ON THE TERROR WATCH
LIST, THERE ARE 480 THAT WERE
STOCKED WITH KNOWN GANG
AFFILIATIONS.
TO TRANSLATE THOSE NUMBERS TO
THE 500,000 OR MORE GOT AWAYS.
NONE NUMBER COMING OUT ON A
DAILY BASIS.
2,000 TO COME ACROSS OUR BORDER
EVERY DAY.
THE BORDER PATROL AGENTS CAN
EVEN GET TO.
WHAT IS DISTURBING ABOUT THIS IS
THE EXTENT THAT THEY JUST
DISMISS THIS AS IF WE SHOULDN'T
CARE WHAT'S HAPPENING AT OUR
BORDER.
GOD BLESS BILL MELUGIN FOR
SEEKING THE FACTS.
WE'RE TRYING TO DO THE SAME
THING IN CONGRESS.
>> Ainsley: THE 23 NUMBER WAS
UP UNTIL DECEMBER.
NOW WE ARE IN THE APRIL, IT'S
42.
WHEN JEN PSAKI SAYS IT IS .00 X
PERCENT OF HOW MANY ARE COMING
OVER, ALL IT TAKES IS ONE.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THAT IS THE TRUTH.
WE SAW THAT OBVIOUSLY WITH A
TRAGEDY IN NEW YORK IN 2001 ON
9/11.
THESE ARE OVER STAYS.
WE'VE GOT PEOPLE THAT WE KNOW TO
BE DANGEROUS INDIVIDUALS.
IT IS NOT JUST THE TERROR WATCH
LIST.
THE 480 AFFILIATION OF GANGS.
THE PEOPLE COMING IN WITH
MASSIVE CRIMINAL HISTORIES AND
WE SEE THE CRIMES COMMITTED TO
THE UNITED STATES.
TALK TO THE RANCHERS IN SOUTH
TEXAS AND GETTING IMPACTED EVERY
DAY BY CRIMINAL INDIVIDUALS.
ADMINISTRATION REFUSES TO SECURE
THE BORDER.
IT'S ON THEM AND IT'S
PURPOSEFUL.
>> Ainsley: WE ARE IN THE
MIDDLE OF INFLATION, HIGHEST IN
40 YEARS.
WE ARE PAYING FOR THEM.
$338 MILLION ON INFRASTRUCTURE.
$98 MILLION ON DOLLARS ON
UTILITIES AND FOOD.
33 --
$12 MILLION ON TRANSPORTATION BY
VEHICLE.
LOOK AT THE ENCOUNTERS IN MARCH.
THE HIGHEST IN A VERY LONG TIME.
WE ARE PROBABLY GOING TO SEE
HIGHER NUMBERS IN APRIL BECAUSE
IT'S GETTING WARMER AND IN MAY
WHEN TITLE 42 ENDS, WHAT CAN WE
EXPECT?
>> THAT IS THE EXACT QUESTION TO
ASK.
YOU KNOW BRANDON AND THE PEOPLE
THAT I KNOW AND THE PEOPLE THAT
I TALK TOO REGULARLY.
WE ARE LOOKING AT NUMBERS THAT
COULD EXPLODE FROM THE CURRENT
7,000 OR 8,000 A DAY UP TO
15,000 MAYBE EVEN MORE A DAY IF
THEY REPEAL OR STOP ENFORCING
TITLE 42.
WE'VE GOT A WAY TO SOLVE THAT
PROBLEM.
THAT IS THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY TO CONTINUE TO
ENFORCE TITLE 42 AND FRANKLY GO
FURTHER AND TURN PEOPLE AWAY AT
THE BORDER.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE TIRED OF
THIS.
I'M IN TEXAS RIGHT NOW IN THE
DISTRICT THAT I REPRESENT IN
AUSTIN AND SAN ANTONIO.
I MET WITH A BUNCH OF PEOPLE
YESTERDAY.
THEY WANT OUR BORDERS SECURED.
THEY WANT TO GET THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT OUT OF THE WAY.
TELLING THEM WHAT TO DO IN
LIVING THEIR LIVES.
IT'S A SIMPLE PRESCRIPTION FOR
THE FUTURE OF OUR COUNTRY.
THAT IS WH